all right so starting today there is a
lesser chance of getting a ticket in the
carpool lane if you're driving by
yourself ndot implemented these new
enforcement hours this morning 8 news
now reporter Ryan Matthey shows us the
changes the work being done to
potentially eliminate them all together
well you no longer need a passenger to
hop into some of Southern Nevada's 20
miles of carpool lanes like here on U.S
95 though with a potential future of
getting rid of them all together there
are obstacles now it's just going to get
backed up a lot
more access to carpool what drivers like
David Gleason fear will inversely
increase their morning commute I love
the carpool Lance I got a three-year-old
my wife it helps a bunch he's talking
about 24 7 enforcement that's now just
hours Monday to Friday during the four
busiest hours on the road enforcement on
the weekend eliminated really causing
people to break the law it comes after
the Nevada Department of Transportation
board of directors indicated the HOV
lanes aren't doing what they're supposed
to increase the number of people
carpooling and decreasing the amount of
cars on the road ndot doesn't really
know the impacts just yet so this is
actually all stuff that we still have to
determine but ndot was already evaluate
leading the effectiveness of HOV rules
now public information officer Justin
Hopkins says they now need another study
everything from noise to the effect on
the air quality all information required
by the federal government that needs to
be collected before doing away with HOV
altogether that study is expected to
take at least 18 months at this point
it's a little too early to know if this
shortened time period is going to have
any impact on the effectiveness of the
use of the lanes but that's something
that will be studied and with minimized
hours state troopers can now focus on
other enforcement like speeding and
reckless driving but when we asked on
Tuesday if they'll pursue this shift
Nevada State Police sent the same
statement they sent three weeks ago that
they'll study various methods to ensure
compliance